[Music]
so I did part fiction in an Oscar for
Best Original Screenplay even if it does
almost everything the screenwriting
books tell you not to do like if
nonlinear structure multiple
protagonists no clear goal long
talkative scenes where is it work anyway
and even so much better the first reason
is because the movie keeps us at the
edge of our seats you want that person
watching your film experiencing the film
to be on the edge of the sea yeah I mean
everybody does but you believe that the
techniques you employ do that yes I do
you see the first criteria usual rate
the movie on is how much of a time I was
hooked
versus how much of the time I was bored
with pulp fiction it's almost impossible
to be bored every single scene is
interesting in that movie and that is
because the whole movie is infused with
suspense which brings us to the first
tip tip number one build suspense in
every scene in Pulp Fiction suspense is
mostly created in two ways either by
expectation of something dangerous to
happen or will make us question how will
a certain dilemma or conflict turn out
in every sequence turn t-mobile's
anticipation towards the future by
making promises he makes those promises
by giving us information through
dialogue and characters actions with
that given information us implies
something important or interesting is
going to happen at the end of each scene
so from the moment the promise has been
made and until the arrival of that
promised action everything in between is
steeped in suspense
and when one promise is resolved he
immediately promises another thing to
happen or he introduces another moral
dilemma or another twist so the viewer
you subconsciously have the impression
that is always something happening that
is why pulp fiction grabs you from the
first scene and never lets go so let's
go through a movie scene by scene and
see how just by using that one
screenwriting device the whole film
becomes a suspense masterpiece so right
from the first minute of the movie we
are hooked forget it feverishly
the couple is planning a robbery
immediately we expect highly risky
situation coming up three or four in the
second scene from the moment Vincent and
Jose
take their guns out of the trunk we
expect somebody will get shot we should
have shared
the deal so we are engaged to the end of
this scene then Marcello stirs butch to
throw the fight night of the fight you
may feel a slight sting that's pride now
we are questioning but butch obey him
when Vincent and Butch have a
confrontation at the bar in my front
local you expect they will knit again
and one of them will get seriously hurt
the whole sequence where Vincent and Mia
go on a date is utmost suspenseful just
because Tarantino established beforehand
that Mia's husband Marcellus is
disturbed find crime boss who draws
people from balconies just for touching
me as feet so a lot is at stake in
Vincent and Mia will be tempted to get
together then Mia overdoses stakes are
the highest now until we get the answer
if me I will survive
next butch wins the fight instead of
throwing it now the gap opens will
Marcellus find budge and kill him then
Fabian reveals she forgot Butch's watch
now we are wondering will would you be
able to get the watch without getting
shot
butch encounters must service and he
runs him over with the car
they both recover and Marcelo start
chasing him will he get him
Marcellus and Butch are tied up in the
basement we are questioning with the
managed to escape which escapes and
stops at the door will he go back and
help Marcellus he decides to help him
will he be able to save him he saves him
what happens now
well now they be even about the fight
back at the apartment we see there is a
fourth man in the bathroom will he kill
Vincent the Jules
Vincent shoots Martin in the face and
the whole car is covered in blood will
they be able to hide the car before
someone reports them to the police
Jeanie's we have a ticking time-bomb
situation they need to clean the car and
get out of the house before Jimmy's wife
comes home and panics back at the
restaurant
the couple starts a robbery and we are
wondering what will happen when pumpkin
comes to Jules we know Jules is a
cold-blooded hitman but pumpkin is also
an unpredictable robber so we can't wait
to see the final confrontation so when
you're writing a screenplay always try
to make big promises which promises you
create the desired tension in the
audience and it's precisely because of
the tension and suspense that those long
talkative scenes work so well in Pulp
Fiction now if you want those scenes to
be even better your character should
always have interesting topics to talk
about tip number two give characters
universal human topics to discuss people
always praised Tarantino's dialogue but
why is his dialogue so good yes every
character has a distinctive voice but
it's not just how they talk it's also
what they talk about inter auntie no
gives them really interesting topics
that we can all identify with let's look
at a few examples uncomfortable silences
why do you feel it's necessary to yak
about Bullock nor will he be comfortable
I'm sure we've all felt like this when
have you met someone you don't you just
love it when you come back from the
bathroom to find your food waiting for
you it's a good feeling right I
personally had my brand-new car
scratched and I can so identify with
this silly what was your dream
who doesn't like conversation about
dreams and their meaning was a foot
massage a foot massage nothing bad is
eating her [ __ ] I know but the same
[ __ ] ballpark
ain't no [ __ ] ballpark leave but foot
massages told me we act like they don't
but they do
cool hilarious debate and difference in
opinions on another identifiable topic
funny thing by Europeans what it's
little differences I definitely noticed
those differences when I travel if you
watch those examples closely those are
the exact same themes and topics that a
stand-up comedian would use those are
themes we are all subconsciously
thinking of we are just not aware of
them when you identify with the
conversation topics he also identified
with the character because you want to
find out his opinion on the subject and
since most characters in pulp fiction
are criminals those universal human
topics made a more humane and more
relatable so go watch some stand-up
shows then google unique human topics
and think about your own funny
conversations you had with a friend and
then put all those interesting debates
in your characters mouths so now you
have suspense and interesting
conversations now you only need one more
thing for scenes to be really amazing
interesting characters tip number three
make the best characterization possible
for all your characters even the minor
ones because you are a character doesn't
mean that you have character there is a
difference between characterization and
true character which we'll get into tip
four but let's first deal with
characterization this is what Robert
McKee says in his book story
characterization is the sum of all of
the world qualities of a human being
everything knowable through careful
scrutiny h & IQ sex and sexuality star
of speech and gesture choices of home
car and dress education and occupation
personality and neuro city values and
attitudes
Tarantino does characterization
extremely well every character in Pulp
Fiction is unique and interesting and
have their own voice his characters are
so stylized they are almost caricatures
lie just look at outer appearances for a
start the example first we have two main
characters in black suits a white guy
with the stylist Flo haircut and an
earring and a black guy with Jerry curls
and sideburns
Jerrica is meant to be a big effort
first which would be even more
distinctive nia also has a book with
banks where unique hairstyle then
supporting character Marcello's is this
huge guy with bald head big earrings a
bandit and a gag ball even the minor
characters have unique look for example
Lance's wife Jodi with all the piercings
then if we look at attitudes and style
of speech means it is more quiet
he talks slowly and it is because he
isn't Haring most of the time but he
wants respect I said a please would be
nice I don't mean disrespect ok I
respect you I still have people barking
orders at me and so on the contrary
jewel speaks fast and enthusiastic and
gets excited about things this is a
tasty burger this some serious go
amazing again very unique and
distinctive pumpkin a honey bunny speak
in a British slang my services dialogue
is calm precise and authoritative taxi
driver
Esmeralda Villalobos speaks with a very
mysterious sexy voice and seems to be
obsessed with death turn Tina basically
on a character from a short feeling
curdled where she cleans up after
murderers see that is the lengths he
will go even for the minor characters he
would find inspiration for them in other
sources and then he would develop them
further on his own and you should do the
same if you want to make characters more
interesting you should make them either
powerful wealthy highly skilled at
something useful unusual eccentric
physically attractive funny dangerous
extraordinary and many of those traits
characters in Pulp Fiction already
possess Marcela's for example is
powerful wealthy and dangerous
Mia is physically attractive unusual and
eccentric but the perfect example of a
character that is highly skilled at
something useful is mr. wolf he is a
cleaner who takes care of the evidence
from criminal actions he has such a high
reputation that other characters feel
totally safe when he arrives I'm Winston
wolf
I saw problems they trust him completely
and they're sure he will get them out of
the mess he is really interesting to
watch from a thottie coal fast and
efficient under pressure he is his
character was so iconic that even 30
years later they are making commercials
with him so all this was
characterization but if you want to
reveal true character you must give your
characters moral choices how they choose
under pressure this is who they really
are behind looks
status mannerisms and jobs first out it
over alright tip number four give
characters moral choices and make them
choose under pressure if we go back to
Robert Maki's book story
here's his definition of true character
true character is revealed in the
choices a human being makes under
pressure beneath the surface of
characterization regardless of
appearances who is this person at the
heart of his humanity what will we find
is he loving or cruel generous or
selfish
strong or weak truthful or a liar
courageous or cowardly the only way to
know the truth
is to witness we make choices under
pressure to take one action or another
in the pursuit of his desire as he
chooses he is so think of clever
situations for the characters where they
are pushed to make moral choices and
then make sure everyone gets what they
deserve
based on the choices they make most of
the characters in the movie are given
choices and they make the choices that
they make and they pay the price for the
consequences or they live this health
tale
they're basically seeks significant
moral choices in part fiction let's
first look at butcher story and then
Vincent and Jules story first
butch makes two important moral choices
there's one he makes a choice to do a
very an honorable thing he actually
makes the deal with Marcellus Wallace to
throw the fight he doesn't have to
Marcellus doesn't say throw the fighter
you're dead he makes it for money and he
takes the money and he screws Marcellus
with it but he actually ends up living
to tell the tale because he actually
does make a moral choice later when he
goes back to save Marcellus choice
number one butch chooses to dog across
Marcellus and because of that
amoral choice he ends up being chased by
an armed Marcellus and ends up bound and
gagged in the basement
choice number two but then butch makes a
moral choice and saves
service and because of that choice he is
not even with Marcellus and he's free to
leave town with Fabian and the money now
right now he's not looking over Selleck
as he did the moral thing he actually
got away with it then we have Vincent
and Jules story they make for moral
choices all together choice number three
Vincent goes on a date with my services
wife Mia and she's flirting with him so
he has a choice to make either to have
sex with Mia or to respect his boss's
wife he makes a moral choice not to have
an affair and that choice turns out good
for him he saves me a from the overdose
and he stays on good terms with
Marcellus then the shooting miracle
happens now juice and Vincent have
choices to make whether to believe it
was a miracle
or not if you just look at the case of
John Travolta and Sam Jackson it would
suggest well okay
Sam Jackson made the good choice made
the right choice and bless he prospers
and John Travolta pays no attention to
it and thus we know he dies choice
number four Jewish chooses to believe it
was a miracle and decides to leave the
life of crime he makes a moral choice
and therefore he survives choice number
five Vincent on the other hand choose to
ignore it was a miracle and continuous
with old life of crime and therefore he
dies choice number six in the last scene
of the movie Lucy's face with the
screenplay is final choice he could
easily killed pumpkin but he chooses not
to do so and with that he proves he
really is a changed man and that choice
turns out good for everyone involved and
they all walk out of a restaurant alive
less moral choice in the movie is always
of ultimate importance because with that
choice we find out who the protagonist
really is at his core and how he changes
which also defines his character arc
also with that final choice we get the
team and the logline of the movie which
now becomes part fiction is a story
about the Hitman who finds Redemption
and leaves the life of crime forever
moral choices have the biggest emotional
impact on the audience because they make
us question our own choices in life is
it worth the risk to treat with the
girlfriend from somebody I know is it
worth it to double-cross a friend for
money to the help of friend even if it
means I can get seriously hurt
should I leave the old life and start a
new one and become a better version of
myself we identify with Jose
deep inside we are all trying to become
better people from try and Wingo and
trying real hard to be the shepherd so I
see under all that Tarantino swaggy
dialogue and violent chaos and nonlinear
structure underneath it all is actually
a very simple and logical moral story
which is easy to follow tip number five
make sure the story is simple clear and
easy to understand
remember clarity is the most important
aspect of the screenplay
if you are still confused they will
disengage and it will take them out of
the story I know as a viewer
the minute I start getting confused I
check out of the movie my you know you I
think an audience has like this
umbilical cord to the to the screen and
it gets severed when when confusion
comes and therefore you lose them
exactly now for the audience not to get
confused first thing you should do for
the basis of your screenplay you should
always take the most simple stories and
plots that are easy to understand do a
search online for classic plots or basic
dramatic situations or go read summaries
from Shakespeare novels then take those
oldest plots and insert them into a
unique story world and into your genre
that is exactly what Tarantino did in
Pulp Fiction the idea with in the case
of Pulp Fiction that would be kind of
cool is to take three separate stories
and make them be the oldest stories in
the book you will there be the hoodlum
has to go out with the boss's lady but
don't touch her the Bruce Willis story
that's the boxer is supposed to throw
the fight and he doesn't and now the
mobs after him well we've seen that
before resilient so in Pulp Fiction we
have three simple classically structured
stories with the conventional conflict
clear motivations and a protagonist with
the problem to solve story one Vincent
must take Nia out and entertain her but
must not have sex with her story too
butch must retrieve a valuable watch and
get out of town before Marcellus kills
him story three Vincent and Jules must
clean up a body car before their
friend's wife gets home
see again very simple problems
crystal-clear motivations in viewers
understand what's at stake right away
without having to do any extra
explanations or expositions now if you
then want to interview those three
stories and have a nonlinear structure
second thing you should do for the
viewers not to get
used is to make sure that when we jump
in time between stories you will should
always know exactly where we are at my
storyline jumps all over the place in
fact forward yeah back and forward
I don't think pop fishing for all of its
goings in and around I mean I don't
think it's hard to watch at all you have
to watch then once you do that then you
can follow it it's easy it's easy to
follow it is easy to follow and we don't
actually jump all over the place as was
just mentioned in the interview we
actually jump in time just two times in
the movie and turn Tino makes sure that
those two jumpings are perfectly clear
he does that with memorable unique
quotes so as a viewer you remember them
let's look at those two examples juice
is quoting an easy kill which is very
memorable then we jump back in time to a
fourth man and we hear Jules quoting an
Ezekiel in the background you
immediately know where we are
pumpkin shouts Castle cafe in the first
scene then in the last scene we feel the
quote again that song so we remember
that we are back at the restaurant
another device Trentino uses to make us
aware where we are in time our clothes
of Jules and Vincent as gangsters there
were classical black suits in the
beginning then suddenly in the bar we
see them in funny t-shirts and shorts
and we immediately notice something
isn't right
then later we see they were forced to
change clothes because of the bloody
suit so now we become aware that the
scene in the bar happened after the
shooting in the car to make sure the
viewers would notice the difference in
outfits they had to work something
totally out of character and they did
also to make it even more clear all
other characters are asking them what's
with the funny outfits they look like a
couple of dorks what's with the outfits
you guys going to a volleyball game or
something so now you made sure that the
movie is easy to understand now another
thing you want to do is make the movie
as cohesive as possible or in other
words make sure everything is connected
and the best way to do this is with
setups and payoffs tip number six
includes setups and payoffs part fiction
has numerous setups and payoffs on
different
of importance and expertise let's start
with short one-liners which are
relatively easy to include in the
rewrites Berger metric system
I get the metric system it was not a
court etiquette they call it a Royale
with cheese you know why they call it
that because of the metric system check
out the big brain on bread uncomfortable
silences pay what uncomfortable silences
that would you call an uncomfortable
silence it's bright him with you that's
prime then we have some mid-level setups
when Vince visits the drug dealer we set
up the de heroin is very strong which
then pays off with me as overdose and we
also set up a place where Vincent later
drives to save Mia's life that
threatening tension between Vincent and
Butch later pays off with Butch killing
Vincent and of course in the first scene
of the movie we set up a robbery which
then pays off in the last scene when
Vincent and Jules confront the robbers
then we have the second best setup of
the movie which is setting up that
Marcellus Mia's husband almost killed a
man for giving me a foot massage number
service is simply Vincent has to take
Nia out for a date and not touch her
internal Tina emphasize that setup from
three different perspectives just Erised
the tension and expectations first Jules
tells Vincent
they took him out on his patio threw his
ass over the balcony since the end he
cannot developed a speech impediment
then I got the bar makes fun of Vincent
so I take me of my happy made me not yet
funny then Vincent asks me about it and
yet even another way is that he was torn
out of a window by ourselves because of
you I mean I understand that Marcel's is
very very protective of you so but now
we are definitely convinced Marcel's
will kill Vincent if he touches me and
Mia is coming on to him that creates
some amazing conflict we are now dying
to know if something will happen between
me and Vincent and that is just because
of that skillful setup now let's end
this tip in this video with a
masterclass of all setups the golden
watch scene this is a five-minute scene
that sets up just one thing basically
this watch is very valuable let's
reverse engineer and ask ourselves why
is it so important that we establish
that this watch is so precious later in
the movie Fabian forgets watches watch
so Bujji decides to go back to recover
the watch even if it is extremely risky
for him since he can be almost certain
that merciless is hitman we'll be
waiting for him and he can get killed so
for his decision to be believable the
watch must really be of enormous
importance to butch so that is why we
need a good setup and we don't just get
a great setup we get a masterclass in
setting expectations
if you ever as a screenwriter want to
learn how to do a setup that something
is available for somebody in the movie I
suggest you go watch the whole scene
again but for the purpose of this video
let's just summarize how many things we
set up to emphasize why that object is
so precious first it's a golden watch so
it has economic value then it was the
first wristwatch ever made this watch
went through Wars it went through many
generations in Butch's family and two
people wore the watch in their asses
Butch's father for five years and
Captain cones for two years now this
watch is priceless
so there you have it six tips you can
learn from pulp fiction now this
screenplay is so outstanding that I
managed to write another eight tips and
made another video for my patreon
supporters so please head over to my
patreon page and subscribe if you want
to see eight additional tips from pulp
fiction on the patreon page there is
also a PDF transcript of this video and
a short video a summary of the structure
of the movie please subscribe to this
channel I will try to create one video
every week if you have any questions
please leave them in the comments below
and let me know your favorite tip my
favorite is tip number four moral
choices now go write your own authentic
screenplays and we meet again in the
next video